this is a production of Cornell
University
ah gee um Dave Grusin my executive
director of New York farm viability
institute and again also thinking
Cornell four minutes together and
developing the program I'll give you a
little background about reliability for
those of you that part aware and then
talk a little bit about our role in
Slough projects over the years so far
mobility started as a grant from USDA
Rural Development in 2003 to Cornell for
an Ag Innovation Center was one of ten
grants across the United States and it
is the only remnant of that program
that's still in operation as that grant
wound down the board of directors for
that grant program which included Ag and
markets Farm Bureau the largest
agricultural commodities in the state
CEO said can we create something that
will outlive this initial grant from
USDA and they came up with the idea of a
farmer farmer directed organization
nonprofit that would provide guidance
for applying cultural research and
education programs for agriculture
across the state of New York and so they
took the I the idea to the list the
state legislature and they liked it and
funded it and in 2005 we were we
received our first shot of funding and
first started funding projects see you
get started heading off in directions
and on the wrong way there we go wrong
direction
yes so we're in 2005 we started our
first projects we have a 10 member Board
of Directors better all farmers and
volunteer on our board we fund a plan
egg cultural research education and
business development projects across all
agricultural commodities in New York
State that across all areas of the state
we utilize an outcome-based funding
model we the board wants to know what
will be measurably different at the farm
level as a result of funding this
project and all of our projects are
reviewed by farmer review panels we have
17 review panels that look at different
cultural areas and we activate those
panels based on the applications that we
receive in any particular grant year 17
review panels and we engaged over 100
dairy farm well and over 100 farmers on
those review panels and in this past
year we've also added Agri service
professionals to those panels as well
we're always we're trying to recruit
people so if anywhere it's interested in
the grant reviewer for prime value
bility projects let me know we can put
you put you to work
in January and February reviewing
proposals so in terms of soil health
projects we funded soil health projects
in the very first year of our existence
in 2005 we funded two projects they were
soil health oriented and since that time
we've funded 41 soil health related
projects or projects that contain soil
health components and across nine
different organizations they used
utilize our funding some of those
organizations certainly include Cornell
we as Dave mentioned earlier we have
some of the funding for the soil health
soil test and getting it utilized more
widely across the state we provided some
funding to they've mentioned Elsa
shields and the nematode work we've
provided funding Kanellis to Ellison
over the years for that
provide funding to nofa New York for
some of the soil health workshop their
work that they have done and and also a
project that we funded with American
Farmland trust a couple of years ago
looking at interceding in corn so a
number of projects over those 41
projects we invested over three point
six million dollars in soil health
related projects since 2005 so I'm not
insignificant
in the areas that we've looked at in
terms of soil projects with fund
projects in grain production forage
production viticulture vegetables some
of our news work in minimum till and
vegetables no-till vegetables high
tunnel soil management and manure
management projects um it's a name a few
there in terms of what we've done now so
in 2018 and going forward
2018
we had a kind of a special emphasis on
soil health we wanted to get project
leaders whose projects that didn't
really falling in line as a soil health
project but might have soil health
implications for example we funded a lot
of vegetable production work in flower
production work in high tunnels nobody
thought of us early and all the sudden
boom we have soil health problems and
issues in high tunnels so now we need to
resolve those issues nobody thought
about that with finding project funding
two researchers who are applying various
chemicals and additives in soil to
control insects or diseases but not were
you thinking necessarily about the
impact on soil health so we're going to
try and get people to start thinking
about how their projects might be
related to soil health in 2019 we're
gonna maintain a focus on soil health
and also encourage projects to be
submitted in the soil health arena those
projects have sought to be good quality
projects they will not receive any
preferential treatment they still have
to compete with all of our other
projects going going forward so I heard
bill so one thing I will say in closing
here is know that that part of my
ability Institute and our board is
committed to soil health long term and
in sort of staying in the game and we're
looking forward to the development of
the soil health roadmap that will be
talked about later today and I think the
guidance that that document will
hopefully provide to universities to
extension associations to swim water
conservation districts to agencies to
NGOs like American Farmland trust and
others and help to consolidate and
coordinate the work that's done in the
soil health arena and farm viability is
looking forward to funding those kinds
of activities across all those
organizations in the future so thank you
very much and I'll turn it over to Jeff
take us to lunch
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu